first one okay so i
can pull up the uh screenshot so i saw
this screen this like thing on
my explore page and then i looked it up
this is the video that came with it bro
getting head on national tv
you guys haven't seen this no funny let
me see this he does
seem like he's getting ahead on national
tv new reporting on something that we
talked about at the top of the hour
the white guy administration is handling
the transition with the incoming biden
team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our entire kid
it is weird that's a good idea oh [ __ ]
that's so good
you already know what it is that news
reporter the white one
um he got onto twitter and apologized
for cursing on
live television he said that he somehow
thought that
he accidentally like cut off the webcam
and only the audio was going
and so he thought somehow like he wasn't
on screen anymore and that's why he
cussed not that he was
getting sucked bro he looked were they
were they mad at him for
cussing yeah yeah you're not supposed to
cuss on cnn man
people act like that's not everyday talk
well it should be
it should be fine if you cuz they
probably won't have them back done no
bro they act like kids are watching cnn
that's
that's a fair point you know definitely
an adult it's an adult program
also it should be some kind of exception
for the good head like how are you
supposed to control yourself right
first of all i thought he was right
ahead with the i don't think so i don't
think he was
but it does seem like it when i first
saw i was like i can see
i don't think he looks more confused
than anything let me see the video look
down his phone's like
[ __ ] yeah see but he did it twice
yeah i'll show you that one next he
doesn't look like he's getting hit
no look at the face no he's just like
handling the deep breaths what about the
deep breaths
or not handling it we should say to a
certain exercise this time
involves our intelligence community uh
ken what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
first of all yeah
wouldn't you be able to hear it
okay okay let me just i feel like you'd
be able to hear it
yeah that's good i don't think he's
getting it i don't think he's getting it
right i think he just got some text
yeah he realized he wasn't on yeah
someone texts him probably saying hey
you're
sat on yeah okay uh so every year we
look at what pornhub has to offer with
like what term is the most popular
search thing in each state and they came
out with theirs yesterday hell yeah oh
that's cool zoom into that chin let me
see
you click on it uh wyoming
man exactly damn i can't read it yeah oh
maryland colorado
wouldn't that be ass south dakota
wrestling
utah rhode island pegging
wait what rhode island said what pegging
all right virginia sloppy [ __ ] i love
how they just have florida california
swag what the [ __ ] what is that
alaska got no nut in november oh how
about pennsylvania
fat ass hey where's arizona what does
arizona say i don't know what yeah what
louisiana
where's arizona louisiana is popeyes
that's messed up oh
shout out to montana anal cream pie
navajo is that what it says yes
navajo for arizona indian
minnesota pov alabama big booty new york
foot job
vermont threesomes missouri accidental
[ __ ]
oh hello we need to go to virginia
tennessee's disgusting
granny home on virginia do we have any
shows out there
uh no okay oh tennessee is getting ready
for malik to come i know it's cool
what's tennessee say
granny we are headed there
so messed up yeah somewhere weird right
yeah jordan oh west virginia bbw
my justin okay look oklahoma cheerleader
you love that [ __ ]
oh my god kentucky is among us what is
it among us is like a video game
what oh like anime no but it's like a
little
little creatures some like what yeah
what's the point of this
dude we just talked about this every
year double penetration
wait hold on oh the threesome washington
double penetration
good for that what's the compass
i don't know what did you say like
you be s suckabus wait wait wait wait
wait wait where do you see this at what
oh again oh type that in chill
connecticut is wedgie i know
as like evil [ __ ] and then have sex oh
that's some weird
oh [ __ ] that's washington is it weird
that's something yeah that's like
food yeah like hansel and gretel that's
weird yeah okay
yeah if you gotta dress up for sex
that's kind of sex matters
it's like jennifer's body you know weird
somebody though dude that should
basically say the the weirdest people in
this state who's got yoga pants
i thought that would be california new
york
to the left far left who is that that's
iowa
how about how about they say illinois
chicago dot
south dakota wrestling y'all gay what
about those other countries
or other countries other states like
vermont maine what they look like well
merely got that she's
is threesome it's so hard to see maine
is daddy
daddy indiana goth yeah i want to go to
new jersey is that just feminists that
are dominating
dominatrix i think nebraska wife swap
that makes sense west coast wisconsin
got uh
bondage if anybody would like who shout
out to kansas chubby
they search for chubby yeah okay ohio
oklahoma cheerleader
i told him there's one just for you what
about ohio cougars
yeah very strange this should say the
weirdest people in each state
yeah yeah i mean you go to gotcha sex
mess
this one trying to be funny it's
exhausting though
but same thing with people acting tough
or guys trying to be funny because
it's like if you do press which you're
the one the og's who still does tons of
radio press
all of it yeah you're the one that got
me back into it thank god
because so many people told me not to do
it don't do it you already sold out your
shows
you don't need to do
that doesn't mean you don't do radio you
still do radio it doesn't mean
everyone in town knows you're there
there's people that don't even know who
you are
yeah that's all yo man if you're
someone's going to give you a free
shot at advertisement their audience but
you don't have this some of that radio
[ __ ] they're like
so man uh the material tonight what can
we expect give
give us give us a little taste of it
well those those guys you don't do
yeah but there's some there's some guys
that you yeah there's some big boys
come on man you gotta do i do them all
there's still some like huge radios i
mean there's guys well i'll turn down
radio you know what i mean
some of them are bad and you know
they're somewhere i'm like no i can't do
them but
at every market i'm doing two or three
for sure especially if they're the big
dogs like there's something like in ohio
i forget his name there's a really big
dude there
obviously breakfast club if you go to
new york like they're that
syndicated oh there's a lot in new york
yeah oh my god
shannon you did breakfast club recently
though yeah i love breakfast
they've been with me since day one
listen to it i mean still to the
i mean damn it every day yeah
charlemagne is the one that got me in
me too yeah he's he's great man
charlemagne then dj
i had no idea he's you know i mean that
he kind of vouched for me to get in
i think i don't know if he bounced for
me but he
the minute i walked in i was like
nervous this is years ago by the way it
was like
10 years ago oh damn and just in between
the break he's like man i'm such a fan
of yours and i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah thank you yeah
you ever
where he's in the la jacket because
that's recent right i don't know
we're in the blue la jacket oh that one
scroll up chin
is that the [ __ ] on this uh my no mine
is you don't have that jacket
let's go ahead and press
[Music]
god
you know the difference between are you
ever being a bar
yeah man you ever get so drunk you
hey are you ready it's tough to get on
breakfast club like charlemagne vouch
for me because i did
brilliant idiots with him andrew schultz
oh nice i did that before and then i was
even planning to do it and then
uh charlemagne texts me yeah i was like
yo you got time tomorrow i'm like
sure as [ __ ] dude they're they're the
best radios there's no reason why this
one
they're so [ __ ] good envy is perfect
and
angela bro you have seen charlie is a
sneaker head too but yeah i've seen his
car collection
yeah me and him just talk cars all yeah
he has
he's got cars oh my god yes car's
freaking i didn't follow him on
instagram it was just too it was
it felt like you're too much too much
you want to dig a deeper hole buddy joe
hold on
i'm just saying oh eventually yeah oh
yeah
so how long after leno cause you said
you were working at nordstrom yeah
so how long after that after leno did
you like
work didn't have to work that job after
leno i got a commercial for amp mobile
they used to sponsor
the ufc that's how i got to see hoist
fight uh
matt and um and uh
i got a commercial deal right after the
tonight show
damn and they paid me fat this guy's
dude this guy was from australia or some
[ __ ]
he had so much money and he was like
i'll pay this much a show
uh we go and uh uh we go and uh
oh god i don't even know what i'm saying
right no
he just right off the tonight show and
what he did is he was doing like these
uh
he would get a bunch of people that sell
phones to come and he would entertain
them
before he would introduce the new phone
that he's trying to get them to sell
so he would have like dancers a comedian
and all that
and he made me close these shows and he
would pay me
fat bro damn like he would pay me so
fast
eight shows i was like dude i don't need
to work for like two years
then he gave me the commercial so then
did you call nordstrom rec did you go in
or like i'm out yeah
i just yeah no no i just i was like but
they all knew because i was doing stand
up there
so they all knew like if something
happened i was gonna i was gonna bounce
i can tell you it was like a different
customer to get shoes from bruh yeah
he's a great
killing again he's killing it
i was the worst employee at nordstrom
what do you mean
because it's the one where it's not
nordstrom it's nordstrom rack
it's the one where they all the shoes
are on the floor so you're looking for a
matching third
so they give you one and then you go to
the back and i'm supposed to find the
other one
it's like dude i would never [ __ ]
look for it it's a nightmare
i would never look for it i would just
come back and i go someone must have
tried it on it's out there somewhere if
you want to look at it
you don't worry i would i would do it i
swear to god i go yo
uh someone tried this on obviously
because it's not back there because it's
so neatly
nice by the way what you see out there
it looked just like that in the back
it was so bad yes it would say yeah it
would just be like size eight heels it
would be all black heels yeah
so if you got a black heel and an eight
you would just go to this bin that said
eight heels and you had to like dig
through and i can only imagine the one
by lax was just like that was the worst
one yeah the worst one damn damn i was
so happy to quit
so happy the worst job you've ever had
that was the worst job
no borders books was worse borders worse
i feel like because i had to wake up at
i had sleep apnea and had to wake up at
five
five five to nine it just got to the
point and they would
i don't know what the [ __ ] dude they
would get books
you know those those uh mystery novels
whatever they're called like a paperback
and there's a collection there's a
series yeah you know what i'm talking
about yeah
well you would pull them rip the front
cover because that's how they get their
their credit back right so you rip the
front cover off and you mail the front
cover to the
publisher and they will refund you for
that book right
so that's what they do when you have a
bunch of stale books on the shelves so
it was my job to pull all these books
rip the covers and then the big fat part
of the book you just threw in the
garbage
and i was like why don't you give this
to like schools that need books
blah blah and they're like no no no it's
more of a tax problem
than anything we'd rather just throw it
away and just not deal with it and i'm
like
all right that's [ __ ] up because i i
could take these books
but anyways that's what they were doing
they were throwing these books away and
you just
you just sent the cover back to the
publisher and they would refund them
and then two weeks later the same books
would come weird
i'm like why the [ __ ] did we throw these
books anyway yeah i was about to say
it's an ongoing cycle
bro i hated that job so much kids i was
putting novels
in the in the bible section i didn't
give a [ __ ]
i give a [ __ ] we had so many books
and only four hours to stock them bro i
was sticking cartoons in
in [ __ ] biographies i they were all
[ __ ] up
does your son have to work any job like
that or no he doesn't get away from it
man he's good
he wants story he wants to work at a
bagel uh western bagel he keeps talking
about i want to work at western base
good for him that was what i said he's
like dude i'm gonna save all my checks
i'm like this [ __ ] kid has
no idea what life is right now
western bagel yeah that's working all
right wait so with sleep apnea you have
that machine
yeah i still have it yeah it's bad man
it's really bad but
it was really bad back then because i
didn't have a machine
yeah so i was always like falling asleep
and [ __ ] it was bad
yeah but that was dude borders books man
that was fun
you want to know my hustle at borders
i'm going to get busted for this
so borders would send sample cds right
okay sample cds right because they had a
cd section
and they would give borders samples or
whatever
new cd came out and you would play it in
hopes that people go oh what's that song
and then you take them over right that
was their hustle right okay
when they were done playing these cds
they would put them in the in the in the
uh the break room for the employees and
there was this bin right
it was just say free cds right you take
whatever you want and they were never
really good
right it was always like beethoven and
all this other [ __ ] right
but every now and then you would get
like a mariah carey right so i would
take a mariah carey yeah
and then i would take like a beethoven
and then i would go to amoeba
you know what mivonne yeah sunset yeah
this is what broke people do to get
money right
so i would go to amoeba and i would sell
it thinking that mariah carey would get
the most money right
mariah would get maybe a buck a buck for
the cd or buck 50
right beethoven got five
bucks yeah because it was like the
classical
four cd set right it was like all the
songs
they gave you five six bucks right so
then i was like
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna let the staff
take the new releases because everyone
always wait for the new releases right
and you were only allowed to take one of
the new releases right so if i got
mariah carey then another person got
whatever right
so then i was like but no one's taking
the classical bro
i cleaned the house man i was making
this change to cool four or five hundred
a month oh damn are you serious
one beethoven yes because he wouldn't
have
blocked they would have all these like
classical pieces the new york symphony
they would have all these it was just
stack up and no one would take it
and then i was just like clink give me
that [ __ ] yeah
my son had diapers all the time that's
why i like i like hustle i love hearing
stories like that but which might
could it couldn't have been me i don't
know yeah but they didn't care about
those because
there were so many of them oh it was a
new relationship so amoeba didn't give a
[ __ ] they
they had they had it all right yeah they
had 50 but mariah carey's but
beethoven's hardcore
beethoven
oh
[Applause]
it's a street fight right now clearly
it's like younger guys yeah right like i
don't know probably mad over 2k
now this guy you're going to see at the
end of the video he's trying to get a
lick in
but he can't find the letter which one
over here the guy right there in the
grave
he's gonna like the fight is over there
he's gonna walk around this table
and smack dude ass you are we sure this
is
looks like in it does don't worry just
watch it joe
what's the guy watch you coming around
he's trying to get a lick look at that
ass
bad boy you're a bad boy
that's what you are
who ass now that video still looks from
1999.
whatever well hold on wait wait but look
how he just even like that guy's punch
he's punching him in the ass i don't
know whatever i guess the ass is open
look at that ass jiggle yeah bad boy
bad boy now the guy bad boy the guy who
smacked the big guy
the fat guy's ass is also a hefty boy
yeah so he probably knew like oh this is
a [ __ ] gift yeah
because he understands like i think i
know what it is okay he knew that enough
trauma was already put onto this guy the
one thing that was missing
was humiliation and he wanted to
humiliate because he walked away so when
they talked about this later he's like
yo you guys see me humiliate that
you see me slap his ass on the way out
that's the definition i smacked the [ __ ]
out of it yeah yeah
yeah i need to be honest if you got your
ass kicked yeah
and then one guy smacked your ass that's
the only thing you think about
oh i'm telling you you don't even think
about how that was his takeaway
he's like dude who slapped me oh my ass
smacked my ass the fight ended right
there face makes sense who slapped my
ass
[Applause]
i don't smack anyone's asses not even a
good game
okay good game i do
sometimes we're not even playing a game
but i'll say goodbye i'll smack ass
i'll say good game yeah all right i
thought it was just my guess
yeah yeah yeah we'll do a smack your
like when you bring me on stage when you
walk off
why do guys not have asses well you got
a touch i got an
ass yeah i got it i think it's like a
dead lift you got to work out you know
i just don't have an ass i think it's
more oh
my pocket goes in
the only girls who naturally have fat
asses that are asian are usually
filipinos filipinos are kind of thick
but it's still spanish though yeah true
it's still rare yeah
it's not like uh like a big thing like
all you don't have fat asses
yeah most latin girls have flat ass i
mean big ass
oh my say hold on i know but i'm saying
i don't have ass so
yeah that's weird yeah black people have
asses
no really not lebron doesn't what why i
wasn't even gonna go there i bet you
i wasn't even right i bet you he does i
wasn't even gonna go there i bet she
does eventually he has an ass but i
didn't
i don't even know yeah but he don't type
in lebron ass
lebron james is having ass like if
you're if you're a black girl or a
latina girl and you have a flat ass it's
just a nightmare is that because
what a what girl it's a nightmare you're
latin or black girl and you have no ass
yeah like that's your thing yeah man
that's your thing
well damn they got more they got a
personality yeah what about you
i i don't know if that looks like that
he has an ass but it's a cool pose
i bet you lebron's cheeked up i mean
he's lebron james totally
come on that's not bad that's an ass
yeah well me and him
dude he's nicki minaj compared to you
he's talking about ass get up in front
of the camera show everyone the ass real
quick where's this camera i got it
that's my six figure queen dude show me
your flat eyes just show the
show show me flat ass just go show them
how you take a [ __ ] laying down
santa so i think she lays out show them
how you take a [ __ ] like this like hey
oh yeah yeah yeah oh guys
look at that yeah look at me put it in
slowly i'll put it to the camera let the
camera see what's up
oh you have an ass let me see let me see
toe you see it max do you get it let me
see malik uh it's hard to get but yeah
yeah it's a little baggy back there
yeah no no you gotta pull your pants up
so they can see it okay
yeah yeah he doesn't have an ass you're
right no no it's not a major
yeah you don't have an ass you and
taylor swift have the same ass
that's the number one album yeah no
doubt yeah
number one album chin would say you're
curvy
chin showed us this girl built like a
[ __ ] ski
and he's all dude check this out i
thought she was kind of bodied up she's
from europe
he's like russia
from russia jingles get ready everybody
[Applause]
curvy like a noodle yeah it was not uh
i didn't stuff it in her skirt she had
like a great dress on and by the end of
the video it was like
ugh i love it i love how he looked up
towards the ceiling too
i hope this happened like this what's
that sorry that's right
tell me that's not bodied up what look
at that let's go
she's stuffing stuff in her hold on
she's also more
thick because she's stuffing produce
right is that a body
it's kind of thick right i don't even
know what that is
is that supposed to be in a in a big
clock in a tower
oh my gosh
look at that that is awful
look at that
you guys ready for this yeah yeah
no we all make mistakes she's in russia
yeah i think it's wrong we all make
mistakes
oh